[Musik]
appel aus den kliniken ärzte waren
angesichts der lockerung diskussion dass
corona virus zu unterschätzen
perspektive für eltern bis nächsten
donnerstag soll es einen vorschlag geben
wann und wie kitas wieder öffnen könnten
verleihungen schwierigen zeiten beim
deutschen filmpreis räumt system
sprenger achtmal ab
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
unserem nachrichtenüberblick am samstag
und natürlich beschäftigt uns die
diskussion weiter wie wir aus dem
shutdown langsam aber sicher wieder
herauskommen nun liegt die erste woche
hinter uns in der die geschäfte wieder
öffnen durften und etwas leben in die
städte zurück gekehrt ist
doch während die einen drängeln das
alles noch schneller gehen müsse machen
krankenhausärzte darauf aufmerksam wie
es denen er geht die auf den
intensivstationen um ihr leben kämpfen
knapp 2000 kroner patienten in
deutschland müssen derzeit beatmet
werden
von einer überlastung ist das
gesundheitssystem aber weit entfernt
insgesamt melden die krankenhäuser heute
mehr als 32.000 einsatzfähige
intensivbetten davon sind fast 13.000
frei sibylle bassler torge bode unter
das parade berichten husten atemnot
schwere lungenentzündung mit diesen
typischen cupid 19 symptomen wurde
michael zech auf die intensivstation
eingeliefert
fast drei wochen lang musste der
52-jährige künstlich beatmet werden
ein ringen um leben und tod das war
alles wir halt gerade dann aber
irgendwann gekehrt da ist jemand gesagt
hat zu mir
wir müssen uns im ersten kämpfen sind
weiter leben also sein soll sei noch
nicht so weit dass das ungefähr vorbei
ist hier im klinikum im bayrischen
mühldorf haben sie sich auf kur witt 19
patienten spezialisiert
bis vor kurzem hatten sie noch mit
extremsituationen zu kämpfen
mehr als die hälfte der 280 betten
belegt mit corona patienten jetzt gehen
die zahlen etwas runter
unsere belastung hat sich im grund
genommen derzeit fast halbiert im
vergleich zu den spitzenzeiten und das
verschafft uns auch die möglichkeit
jetzt auch wirklich durchzuschnaufen
einmal durchschnaufen bis die
infektionszahlen vielleicht wieder
ansteigen auch auf der intensivstation
der uniklinik sind ärzte und pfleger
noch weit entfernt vom normalbetrieb
zwar sind auch hier kapazitäten frei
längst nicht alle intensivbetten mit 19
patienten belegt entwarnung aber will
hier keiner geben normalisiert sich
vielleicht wir haben so gewisse
geringere anzahl von patienten oder
hätten also das wichtige zweite welle
eine mögliche zweite welle sollte sie
wirklich kommen sind sie darauf
vorbereitet denn die behandlung von
kogit 19 patienten verlangt pflegern und
ärzten alles ab eine 24 stunden rund um
betreuung corona patienten die in was
ich beatmet werden müssen haben ein so
schweres lungen versagen was ich auch
leider nicht innerhalb weniger tage
mittels beatmungs therapie zurück bild
sondern wir sprechen hier von verläufen
von 23 bis zu vier wochen wo sich die
lunge nur langsam erholen
und wenn die wochenlange künstliche
beatmung vorbei ist bei denen die das
virus schließlich besiegt haben ist es
noch lange nicht geschafft denn auf der
entbindungsstation müssen die patienten
erst langsam wieder lernen allein zu
hacken
schauen wir auf die statistische seite
der krise die zahlen laut johns hopkins
universität gibt es in deutschland jetzt
mehr als 155.000 bestätigte corona
infizierte stand vor einer halben stunde
davon gelten fast 110.000 menschen als
genesen und 5802 sind in verbindung mit
dem virus gestorben die zahl der
neuinfektionen ist gesunken
fast 7000 waren es noch anfang des
monats nun 1900 seit einer woche stecken
sich täglich durchschnittlich etwa 2000
menschen neu an
im gegensatz dazu schweden
da nimmt die zahl der neuinfektionen
immer mehr zu nun auf den höchsten stand
seit anfang der epidemie das ist vor
allem deshalb bemerkenswert weil
schweden bei der bekämpfung des virus
einen sonderweg geht kein lockdown keine
ausgehverbote schulen und restaurants
geöffnet
die schwedische regierung vertraut auf
ihren starts epidemiologen und der hält
nichts von verboten
doch die verunsicherung im land nimmt zu
hermann berg frühling in stockholm die
menschen zieht es nach draußen geschäfte
und cafés sind geöffnet normalität auf
den ersten blick es gibt keine strengen
vorgaben wegen corona wer krank ist soll
zu hause bleiben abstand halten kein
zwang es sind empfehlungen zu verstecken
als und wir versuchen die regeln zu
befolgen
aber ich bin froh darüber dass wir nicht
alle schließen denn das bedeutet dass
weniger leute arbeitslos werden
die schwedische linie ist so anders dass
ich mir schon ein paar fragen stelle
im augenblick kann man sagen dass es
wohl funktioniert aber es ist noch zu
früh das zu beurteilen
der mann hinter schweden sonderweg ist
an das techno der oberste staatliche
epidemiologe er bleibt bei seinem kurs
obwohl es inzwischen fast 2200 tote und
18.000 infizierte gibt das land steht
bezogen auf die einwohnerzahl viel
schlechter da als etwa dänemark norwegen
oder deutschland 2000 wissenschaftler
fordern ein umdenken und strengere
regeln ja dass wir eine sehr viel höhere
todesrate haben als unsere nachbarländer
dass es ein zeichen für versagen so ist
das auch wenn man akzeptieren sollte
dass sie die grenze der intensiv
kapazitäten noch nicht erreicht haben
auch immer politik wachsen die zweifel
innenminister dambeck empört sich
darüber dass immer mehr schweden die
abstandsregeln missachten
lassen sie mich ganz klar sein ich will
nicht ein überfülltes außen restaurants
sehen
das geht nicht nur für stockholm sondern
überall und jeder trägt verantwortung
der minister schließt nicht aus dass
deshalb restaurants schon bald
geschlossen werden könnten
das gesundheitssystem müsse auch in zwei
wochen noch funktionieren bei uns in
deutschland wollen kanzlerin und
ministerpräsidenten am donnerstag über
das weitere vorgehen in der krise
sprechen gesundheitsminister sparen war
beim thema lockerungen für pragmatische
lösungen den zeitungen der funke
mediengruppe sagte er
partys oder volksfeste wären extrem
riskant wer dagegen mit dem nötigen
abstand zu anderen in ein geschäft gehen
oder sich beim sport im fitnessstudio
fit halte sollte das tun können aber nur
mit maske das gilt ja vielerorts ab
übermorgen beim einkaufen und in bussen
und bahnen
was aber wenn man sich nicht daran hält
in der zdf- heute- app können sie
nachschauen welche strafe dann droht und
die ist je nach bundesland verschieden
kitas und schulen spielen bei der
eröffnungs debatte naturgemäß eine
besondere rolle
denn für berufstätige eltern war und ist
die situation extrem belastend doch
während viele schulkinder am montag
wieder in die schule dürfen müssen die
kleinen weiter zu hause betreut werden
nicht gerecht sagen viele eltern sie
haben sich jetzt über das internet
zusammengeschlossen und gehen gemeinsam
auf die straße lenken klingel berichtet
raus aus der dreizimmerwohnung der
tägliche spaziergang ist für familie
fischer zur routine geworden
schulen kitas krippen alles ist seit
wochen zu beide sind berufstätig und
langsam am rande ihrer kräfte
gromov ist mit zwei kindern realistisch
gesehen ist nicht optimal und es ist die
ganze zeit auch stress wer kümmert sich
schon die kinder ist saison leichten
fall sogleich zur verhaltensänderung bei
meiner großen tochter zumindest die halt
wie auch die eltern aggressiver
reagieren schneller nicht mehr so viel
geduld haben
so wie familie fischer geht es vielen
eltern in den sozialen medien haben sich
inzwischen tausende zusammengeschlossen
in wiesbaden sind am nachmittag 50 von
ihnen auf die straße gegangen nur so
erlauben es die regeln in der korona
zeit es geht ihnen vor allem um die
kleinen kinder wenn die politik über
schulen und über kinder spricht dann
spricht sie eben nur von schulen
kindertagesstätten und kindergärten
werden noch nicht einmal erwähnt
gleichzeitig wird von jungen familien
aber erwartet dass sie die wirtschaft am
laufen halten und es ist halt für die
kleinen kindern eine katastrophe man
kann es ihnen nicht erklären
sie können es nicht verstehen sie leiden
auch ohne sie leben und uns eltern geht
es vor allen dingen darum dass
perspektiven kommen dass man sich
überlegt wie kann man öffnen noch ist
vollkommen unklar wann kitas wieder
aufmachen
die familien minister beraten aber
aktuell über mögliche erste schritte es
geht ja nicht nur um die frage von
vereinbarkeit von familie und beruf es
geht ja auch um die einschränkung von
kinderrechten kinder brauchen andere
kinder zum aufbacken sie brauchen
mobilität familie fischer könnte sich
auch erst einmal nur wenige stunden
betreuungszeit pro familie vorstellen
jede kleine unterstützung würde
wie geht s weiter fragen sich auch
millionen menschen wenn sie an ihren
arbeitsplatz denken
noch nie waren mehr deutsche in
kurzarbeit derzeit etwa 4 millionen
beschäftigte gut 700.000 unternehmen
haben kurzarbeit angemeldet also rund
ein drittel der dazu berechtigten die
kosten sind kaum abzusehen das
finanzpolster der bundesagentur für
arbeit immerhin 26 milliarden dürfte
schon in wenigen monaten aufgebraucht
sein
dann müsste der bund einspringen es gibt
aber auch firmen die jetzt schon wieder
die kurzarbeit zurückfahren wenn glas
und simon pfanzelt mit einem beispiel
endlich wieder zurück bei der arbeit
nach vier wochen die diana eckert
komplett zu hause war kurzarbeit zu 100
prozent
jetzt wo der laden wieder geöffnet ist
erste kunden wieder hier einkaufen kann
sie zumindest einige stunden die woche
arbeiten
ich bin froh dass es weitergeht in der
format bilder verkauf einfach spaß macht
mit der kunde aber ist jetzt natürlich
anderes verkaufen wie das vorbild war
anders die situation auch nebenan in der
strickerei der firma kaum arbeit deshalb
ist der großteil der mitarbeiter des
wäscheherstellers nach wie vor in
kurzarbeit
um den dramatischen auftragseinbruch
zumindest ein wenig abzufedern
produzieren sie jetzt schutzmasken
doch die massiven ausfällen kann das
allenfalls abmildern
alleine märz haben wir ein umsatzminus
der wirtschaft von minus 40 prozent
april ist noch nicht ganz durch aber es
wird diesen monat schätze ich mal bei 70
bis 80 prozent umsatzminus liegen massiv
die einbrüche auch beim
automobilzulieferer elringklinger durch
den stillstand der bänder bei
autoherstellern mussten auch sie die
produktion in vielen werten zeitweise
komplett stoppen
wir haben zunächst natürlich stunden
abgebaut und machen jetzt kurzarbeit wir
schicken die leute zum teil auch im
urlaub hoffnungsschimmer für den chef im
home-office zumindest teilweise können
sie die produktion wieder hochfahren
langsam und schritt für schritt
doch in euphorie verfällt deshalb keiner
das wird aufs jahr gesehen wirklich die
größte wirtschaftskrise der größte
produktionseinbruch sein den wir alle
erlebt haben werden eine krise die laut
ig metall schon jetzt auch zu
entlassungen führt die meisten
beschäftigt in leiharbeit haben heute
keinen job mehr sind nicht mehr in den
betrieben wo sie vorher war
und natürlich sind befristete
arbeitsplätze massiv bedroht auf rund
drei millionen menschen könnte die zahl
der arbeitslosen in diesem jahr
ansteigen schätzen experten heute ohne
das instrument der kurzarbeit wäre der
anstieg wohl noch viel massiver spanien
ist in europa das land das mit fast
224.000 infizierten am stärksten von
corona virus betroffen ist jetzt gibt es
erste anzeichen dass sich die situation
entspannen könnte
seit zwei tagen werden täglich mehr neu
genesende menschen erfasst als
neuerkrankte in spanien gelten seit
wochen strenge bestimmungen
erwachsene dürfen nur zum supermarkt zur
apotheke oder zur arbeit ab morgen
dürfen nach sechs wochen erstmals wieder
kinder das haus verlassen
allerdings nur für eine stunde die
weltgesundheitsorganisation warnt davor
sich darauf zu verlassen dass ehemals an
corona erkrankte menschen immun gegen
das virus sind dafür gebe es keinen
beleg
in einigen staaten wird diskutiert
genesenden menschen einen pass
auszustellen mit dem sie sich frei
bewegen und wieder arbeiten gehen
könnten
das würde im schlimmsten fall die
ausbreitung wieder beschleunigen
befürchtet die whu im kampf gegen das
corona virus können andere
infektionskrankheiten leicht aus dem
blickfeld geraten masern etwa oder die
malaria an der alle zwei minuten auf der
welt ein kind stirbt in den letzten
jahren wurden große anstrengungen
unternommen diese krankheiten
einzudämmen gerade auch in afrika jetzt
stockt das ganze weil die
gesundheitssysteme in den ärmeren
ländern überlastet sind tim kröger
berichtet
ein einfacher karton mit lebenswichtigen
inhalt damit will die hilfsorganisation
photobox neugeborene beschützen vor
durchfallerkrankungen und dort wo sie
auftritt auch vor malaria aber durch die
maßnahmen gegen cupid 19 wird die arbeit
schwieriger den wir haben andere
provinzen besucht aber das können wir
nicht weiter verfolgen weil die
regierung uns nicht erlaubt nach oben zu
verlassen
die befürchtungen sind groß dass in
afrika durch den kampf gegen das corona
virus andere tödliche krankheiten
vernachlässigt werden ohne ausreichende
verteilung von moskitonetzen und
behandlungen etwa könnte sich die zahl
der malaria todesfälle in diesem jahr
gegenüber 2008 10 auf knapp 770.000
verdoppeln so die
weltgesundheitsorganisation wh
wir haben beim ebola ausbruch in
westafrika gesehen dass wir mehr
menschen durch eigentlich vorher
kontrollierbare krankheiten wie malaria
verloren haben als durch den ausbruch
selbst viele länder hätten bereits
impfkampagnen ausgesetzt um menschen vor
einer krone ansteckung zu schützen so
die whu im kongo wo bereits tausende
menschen durch einen masern-ausbruch
gestorben sind könnten sich
impfmaßnahmen verzögern
wir erwarten dass es dadurch länger
dauert bis sie die masern epidemie unter
kontrolle haben und noch ist nicht
absehbar wie schwer afrikanische länder
von der krise erfasst werden
in berlin sind größere demonstrationen
derzeit verboten
trotzdem haben etwa 1000 menschen gegen
die krone einschränkungen protestiert
auf dem rosa-luxemburg-platz in
berlin-mitte versammelten sie sich und
standen dabei teils dicht an dicht
unter den demonstranten waren auch
rechtspopulisten und bekannte fdp
politiker über lautsprecher forderte die
polizei dazu auf den platz zu verlassen
es gab auch festnahme
es wird immer wahrscheinlicher
deutschland steht wohl vor seinem
dritten dürre sommer in folge förster
und bauern sind alarmiert experten
sprechen von klaren zeichen des
klimawandels
normalerweise fallen im april
durchschnittlich 50 liter regen pro
quadratmeter
diesmal waren es nur 1,5 liter also fast
nichts weil in den böden ohnehin kaum
noch wasser steckt sind besonders die
wälder gefährdet aber auch massive
ernteausfälle zeichnen sich jetzt schon
ab morgen berichtet hier sollte
eigentlich eine blume wiese entstehen
kleine pflanzen und blumen für insekten
und bienen wollte bauer thielking bei
hannover kultivieren doch es ist einfach
zu trocken die triebe haben es gar nicht
nach oben geschafft inzwischen hatte
andere sorgen der roggen wird es
vermutlich auch nicht schaffen eine sehr
kleine pflanze zusammen die ist sehr
blaue schon das hat hunger und extrem
viel durst hier sieht man wenn man die
maus reist in den wurzelbereich ist kein
bisschen feuchtigkeit
das heißt diese pflanze wird oder jetzt
eine bewässerung die ich jetzt vornehmen
werde nicht überleben
in den ganzen april über hat es kaum
geregnet der letzte nennenswerte
niederschlag ist lange her erinnert sich
die leaking er muss wie die meisten
getreidebauern jetzt schon anfangen die
felder künstlich zu begegnen so früh wie
nie der landwirt steckt in einem dilemma
das wasser wird nicht reichen bis zum
sommer entscheiden wo nutze ich das mein
wasser mein wasser airbus für getreide
oder nutze ich eben für kartoffeln wie
das wasser noch mehr brauchen diese
kartoffeln oder schreibe ich halt das
ein oder andere ab das ist mein ganz
großes problem in der ich jetzt in dem
ich jetzt stecke wenn es trocken bleibt
keine leichte entscheidung doch
kartoffeln sind ertragreicher so oder so
rechnet telecom jetzt schon mit einem
ernteausfall denn für die nächsten tage
ist kein regen in sicht
und jetzt vorhang auf für die lola den
deutschen filmpreis
mit großem publikum und jubel auf der
bühne sie ahnen es ein bild vom letzten
jahr diesmal musste es im leeren studio
feierlich werden keine leichte aufgabe
für den einsamen moderator edin
hasanovic laudatoren und preisträger
wurden nur zugeschaltet allerdings zu
einem denkwürdigen abend das drama
system sprenger räumte insgesamt acht
auszeichnungen ab nils schneider
was für ein jubel die elfjährige helen
erzengel hat gerade die lola als beste
hauptdarstellerin gewonnen
natürlich all den leuten danken
in dem film system sprenger spielt sie
ein sozial auffälliges mädchen mit dem
keiner zurecht kommt dass alle vergrault
sie will zurück zur mama die zdf
koproduktion ist der abräumer des abends
bester film beste regie und bestes
drehbuch an nora fing scheidt beste
weibliche nebenrolle an gabriela maria
schmeide sie bringt die preisverleihung
zum funkeln
der abend im leeren studium mit großen
videoleinwänden war für den moderator
eine echte herausforderung aber auch für
die zugeschalteten laudatorin berliner
beckmann das bild ist ein bisschen
verrückt
bester hauptdarsteller ist albrecht
schuch auch system sprenger er gewinnt
gleich zwei preise wird auch bester
nebendarsteller im film berlin
alexanderplatz eine weitere zdf
koproduktion die arbeit ist nicht
ungefährlich weil sie lohnt sich also
danke noch mal ich mach es kurz ist
wieder hatte ich die chance in einem
herzensprojekt durch und durch zu sein
von vorne bis hinten die filmbranche
leidet wie viele im moment geschlossene
kinos abgesagte dreharbeiten ein abhält
liebe leute vergesst die kultur nicht
vergesst die künste nicht sie sind
wichtig zum leben ein abend in corona
zeiten reduziert auf das wesentliche die
preise die filme und ihre macher
vergesst die kultur nicht und deshalb
blicken wir ausnahmsweise zum schluss
noch auf die britischen charts mit dem
ältesten nummer eins hit sänger in deren
geschichte
tom moore weltkriegsveteran und seit
wochen spendensammler in sachen corona
viele millionen pfund hat der 99 jährige
bereits zusammen bekommen und jetzt
singt er auch noch mit viel stimmiger
unterstützung
die hymne die so gut passte nie schaffte
es aus dem stand von null auf eins alles
für den guten zweck
o
[Musik]
möge er noch viele jahre weiter rocken
der frühsommer bleibt immer noch zu
trocken in deutschland aber immerhin
kündigen sich erste schauer an
mehr dazu gleich von essent elli so viel
von uns schön dass sie dabei waren
claus kleber erwartet sie um viertel vor
elf zum heute-journal und morgen freut
sich hier barbara hahlweg auf sie ich
wünsche euch noch einen schönen
samstagabend und sagen tschüss bis
montag
[Musik]
ein stirnband und herzlich willkommen
zum wetter es ist viel zu trocken
derzeit und bisher im gesamten april
sind nur vier prozent des regens
runtergekommen was normalerweise sein
sollte und es herrscht dürre bisschen
1,8 meter tiefe teils extreme dürre oder
außergewöhnliche dürre und daran ändert
sich wenig zumindest in den nächsten
tagen schauen wir auf die europakarte da
wird die kühle luft im norden abgedrängt
im süden ist es immer noch warm ja und
in der nacht da tut sich nicht sehr viel
es wird meist sternenklar seien vor
allem im süden im norden sind mehr
wolken aber die temperaturen sinken
dabei im osten auf null grad hier also
frostig im südwesten sind es acht grad
morgen dann überall trocken zunächst
einmal und sonnig dann im tagesverlauf
von südwesten her einzelne schauer
die können auch mal kräftiger ausfallen
und das bei temperaturen von bis zu 23
grad im rhein main gebiet deutlich
kühler an der nordsee elf grad hier aber
in den nächsten tagen wird es auch dort
allmählich milder
das sehen wir hier 14 bis 25 grad am
montag dazu schauer im süden und dann
endlich ab dienstag mehr regen und
gewitter damit einen schönen abend